بعد التهديدات والتحذيرات على وقع الحرب
في اوكرانيا واشنطن فتحت نافذه الحوار مع
موسكو من اجل تقليل مخاطر استخدام محتمل
للاسلحه النوويه وافقاما كشفه مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي جيك سولفا
مشدده على انها لن تقدم اي تنازلات احاديه
الجانب في ما يتعلق باستقرارها
الاستراتيجيه موسكو كانت اعتبرت في وقت
سابق انها وواشنطن تواصلن الاتصالات في
الامور التي تتطلب ذلك وان روسيا منفتحه
على الحوارات المفيده للطرفين كيف بدورها
كانت قد وضعت شروطا للتفاوض مع موسكو
واهمها استعاده وحده الاراضي واحترام
ميثاق الامم المتحده والتعويض عن جميع
الاضرار التي سببتها الحرب ومعاقبته كل
مجرم حرب وضمانات لعدم تكرار ذلك
اوكرانيا ايدت الولايات المتحده بان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن ليس جادا في
الوقت الراهن بشان المفاوضات ما اثار
مخاوف عالميه ولكنه اقر بان رفض الرئيس
الاوكراني فولو دي ميرسي لينسكي الدخول في
محادثات مع توتا اثار ايضا مخاوف في اجزاء
من اوروبا وافريقيا وامريكا اللاتينيه وهي
المناطق التي ظهر فيها تاثير الحرب على
تكاليف الغذاء والوقود على نحو كبير تقول
صحيفه واشنطن بوست محاسن حضاره العربيه